i think we should start with the news
about season six
how long did you have to keep this a
secret for
oh my god
[Laughter]
and you're talking to the two worst
people in the cast for keeping secrets
amy and i are terrible
we suffered i just want everyone to
realize how much amy and i have been
suffering for months
and been absolutely terrible
like we are so excited you know it's
funny i think db is probably one of the
most veteran
players in the cast he's been on a
bajillion shows and
you know has been gracing our screen
since
since like for decades and but still
somehow db retains this child-like
excitement
for the story you know and then same
year like i've jumped around
and we're still so excited and and giddy
about what we do
and and how it's going to affect people
and like
i think the reason it's so hard for us
to keep a secret is because we're fans
ourselves
of these great yes
we know how excited we get so we know
how excited the fans are going to get
because we're one in the same and and
it's been so hard you guys high five
hi virtual high five hi guys i thank you
and oh my gosh just between like dennis
being
god and michael it just was
it was it was i was we were internally
combusting as well
we're glad that we can now share with
the world how
does having a season six affect where
season five
ends because you guys have not shot
those final episodes yet of 5b
so will there be alterations made to
that ending
so yeah it was a little strange because
we were all kind of you know
wrapping it up and uh so so we got the
news
but just uh like all of us were happy
we're just confused
as to um uh why it came when it came so
i think the writers did some uh um
reshuffling um and uh i just had my you
know my first writer's meeting
uh a few days ago and they are raring to
go
and uh what it sounds like to me without
giving too much away
is they already know how it's gonna end
so i think for them what they're gonna
do now
is the ending that they had planned now
they're just gonna kind of
stretch it out a little bit and so allow
all of our characters some some space
and room to
to to breathe and maybe even tell some
more
some stories about each of the
characters um
that our fans are gonna get a chance to
um
to uh uh get to see us
in in different um ways
and before we get to the end um so i
think that this sixth season is going to
be
i think the sixth season is really for
the fans you know um
to our kind of
long goodbye sure i think you know
exactly i think the sixth season is a
great opportunity
for the writers to not just skip
over a great ending but to really dive
in to a great ending
we were so excited about how it ends and
it's still gonna end that way but even
better
because like db says it's not just going
to be like a montage ending of how
each character ends up but now it'll be
an
episode for you know each episode to see
how they each end up so basically it's
the same
story which is great because we were
given the opportunity to tell a great
story
and now it's just gonna be a great
deeper story
i think it's gonna be really fun my one
pitch yesterday by the way to the
writers involved
i got you guys everyone is so cool at
fighting on the show everyone's like
you know i go i love kung fu i'm like
can
ella
ah like slow motion and then she thinks
she's like flying through the air but
it's really like a menadil
you know
question and then db's character is like
ah she only knew the truth you know
we'll see you okay fight scene
so the intended ending is still gonna be
the intended ending
just now in season okay you guys still
feel the same way about how the show
will eventually end oh my god yes it's
beautiful
it's absolutely beautiful do you guys
feel like this was always secretly the
plan
or are the fans just that amazing
i think the fans are just amazing
but really really i think we're all
professionals and
as much as we love netflix and as much
as we love warner brothers
i think we all know that uh when you
set out and you say this is going to be
the final season of something
and then towards the end you reverse
course
uh it's not just because they love us so
much although we're lovable
i mean obviously the show is doing
really well and it's doing even a lot
better than
netflix and warner brothers anticipated
um
and i'm just listen i'm just glad that
there are people
who are running those companies who were
willing to kind of put the brakes on it
and go hey what are we doing
um we have something great here let's
continue this greatness
i think it takes people who are really
confident and and um and smart
to be able to reverse course because
something good is happening and they
just wanted to
keep the goodness going so
i love it